whatever will be will be our next
category in short subjects this year is
such up this year here back up good a
short subject a short subject is any
picture other than war and peace or the
ten commandments secrets they're so long
oh well the board for this category a
young man who has been a star longer
than even he can remember mr. Mickey
Rooney
how are you Mick fine fine Jerry thank
you very kindly
mr. Lewis honored when arriving ladies
and gentlemen I think that the Academy
had great perception when they invited
me to give away this particular category
for short subjects Oh Nicky I don't
think it's all right but all sensitive
about my height after all I I got my
start in short subjects many many years
ago about 33 years ago in comedies in
the Mickey McGuire comedies
yeah I remember remember those men
constantly they were doing wonderful i
watch them every night what my kids do
on the television now they are oh sure I
see it all the time with my kids no let
me ask you something again I'm just
curious do you ever see any of those
kids used to work with are you kidding
no no Joey I mean we we they're together
over living in a motel off of Kalinga
you're kidding okay everybody is all
together in one room over there
camaraderie like you have never seen it
before got a mom we go over once a week
we have a big kind of a hoedown thing
like a reunion reunion one that's right
it's wonderful to hear that what about
that little dog that used to run through
all the comedies what about him the dog
yeah well he was smart he saved this
money he owns the motel oh I see you
know but outside of that you know every
time I see the Mickey McGuire comedies I
usually cry cry I cry because they're so
nostalgic to me yeah Jerry I I can't
help but cry yeah well I can understand
that no residuals huh
I never stopped to think about it but
that's another reason for crime you know
shook me up a little bit myself I would
like to read the next category if I may
the nominations for one real short
subjects are Constantine counter
crashing the water barrier Robert Young
s'en for I never forget a face and
Cedric Francis for time Stood Still may
I have the envy in New York the winner
is crashing the water barrier
Constantine calcium
I can Baldwin our editor and Reuben
Frank who wrote it and the Saucony
mobile oil company that made it possible
thank you
and now ladies and gentlemen the
nominations for two real short subjects
are George Kay Arthur producer for the
bespoke overcoat
Larry Landsberg for cow dog John Healy
for the darkwave and won't Disney for
small the envelope is in New York the
winner is thus bespoke overcoat George
Kaos
I humbly accept this on behalf of the
cast the two stars mr. Coss off mr. bass
mr. Clayton the director thank you